just 24
of south africans have had two doses of
a covid jab vulnerability enough without
a new variant at large
here in johannesburg and its surrounding
province cases have quadrupled in the
last nine days
and while it's not certain a new variant
may be the cause
it's hard to see them as locked down
again because so many families you know
depend on the different sectors that are
open right now i think it scares a lot
of people a lot we used to be scared
when this thing started but now it's
something that we're living with we
can't be scared anymore
daily cases in south africa are nearly
70 times lower than in the uk but the
sudden spike linked to a new strain so
very different to anything they'd seen
before has put south african scientists
on high alert the first cases were
identified not even 10 days ago and but
that means identification of course it
could be that
the this variant was circulating for
longer and then only those were the
first cases identified so now actually
is what is happening we are going back
to samples that were collected earlier
in november and even late october and we
will see if
people infected at that stage they were
already infected with the new variant
the who has now named the strain with
the greek letter omicron is it more
infectious will it evade our vaccines
researchers in south africa and around
the world are now racing to find out the
variant has more mutations than any
strain seen so far 35 alone in the
crucial spike protein and a
concentration of them in the receptor
binding domain the bit of spike that
binds to our cells
the delta variant which now dominates
the globe has two mutations there the
vaccine dodging beta or south africa
strain had three
the omicron variant has 10 binding
domain mutations
now south africa's vigilance has been
rewarded with travel bans
the reaction of some of
uh
countries
in terms of imposing travel bans and
and such measures are completely against
the norms and standards as guided by the
world health organization
you can understand their frustration but
the last thing the northern hemisphere
wants to see as it heads into winter is
a dangerous new variant i think what we
all think at the moment is the sensible
thing at this stage is to be
precautionary uh and then uh for us if
if things look as if they're less bad
than uh
currently they might be uh then we can
ease back but it makes sense to take
precautions early on uh and in
particular take precautions to slow down
the arrival of this in the uk
today the who was highly critical of
travel bans imposed by the uk and others
on south africa just seven percent of
people on the african continent are
fully vaccinated against kovid here in
the uk many of us are receiving a third
dose
slamming the door on unvaccinated parts
of the world won't keep new variants out
nor will it stop them emerging
only helping to immunise them will do
that
tom clark sky news